les députés européens sont élus au
suffrage universel direct depuis 1979
avant il était désigné par leur état
alors en 1979 l'europe c'était la cee
la communauté économique européenne il
n'y avait que 9 pays et seulement quatre
cent dix députés
aujourd'hui c'est l'union européenne et
27 états alors après les élections de
juin 2009
736 députés siégeront pour cinq ans au
parlement européen
chaque état peut choisir son mode de
scrutin mais tous doivent respecter
quelques règles communes trois principes
communs 1 il s'agit des élections la
proportionnelle de tous ressortissants
des pays membres de l'union
résidant dans un autre pays membre a le
droit de vote et d'éligibilité au même
titre que les nationaux et 3 il y à des
incompatibilités pour la candidature on
ne peut être ni fonctionnaire européen
ni par exemple député budget national
la france opté pour le scrutin de liste
fermée c'est à dire que les électeurs ne
pourront pas changer l'ordre des
candidats sur la liste
certains pays ont choisi un scrutin
national unique comme l'espagne ou le
portugal
d'autres ont préféré un découpage de
circonscriptions comme la pologne la
belgique ou la france les français vont
donc élire 72 députés répartis dans huit
circonscriptions différentes
le découpage de cette année est le même
que celui de 2004 qui était l'année
d'introduction de ce système en france
avant cela la france était une
circonscription nationale unique
nous avons des circonscriptions qui sont
faites de regroupement de départements
ou qu'on peut lire aussi comme des
regroupements de régions qui n'ont pas
de consistance historique et qui sont
qui ont véritablement été fabriqué pour
ces élections européennes
la participation à ces élections
européennes est la grande inconnue
les électeurs ont bien du mal à se
mobiliser et depuis 1979
ce taux de participation ne cesse de
s'effriter la tendance française épouse
à peu près la moyenne européenne c'est à
dire qu'on commence aux alentours de 60%
en 1979 on est à 42 % en 2004 on se
situe dans la moyenne langue alors il ya
des pays qui participent encore moins
comme le royaume uni
c'est pas une énorme surprise donc la
france se tient correctement par rapport
aux autres pays où le vote n'est pas
obligatoire
sur les 27 états de l'union ce sont 375
millions de citoyens qui sont appelés
aux urnes les élections auront lieu du 4
au 7 juin selon les pays le 4 par
exemple pour les anglais le 6 pour les
chypriotes les français voteront le
dimanche 7 juin et les résultats seront
connus le soir même après la fermeture
des bureaux de vote